hey guys how's it going today we're
gonna do a special Q&A with three pretty
good you have to when you make a video
you gotta be in the screen bow and Bri
you have on Twitter to ask you some
question can I help to get her know go
tell him to get me I don't want to get
lost
Bri what's your favorite ethnic food its
Pisa
I think I come all right it's Belle
going to play a role in Brees wedding
oh that's a good question do you think
you will where you're gonna do it you're
gonna be you're gonna eat the ring and
you probably would what is your favorite
thing about meeting fans who me free up
sinking I quit these are my questions
oh yeah oh I don't really have any fans
really are you kidding me they love you
again we're not well okay the floppy
night sky do away with this okay sleep
yep none of that we're not gonna play
with that we're we're done with this
you're done with it we're done with this
mm what's your favorite 90s cartoon oh I
used today artal 90s I think it was
nineties or what all Doug do you have a
dog has Brianne read your book no boat
you can't reenact chily is not read my
book everyone in my entire family has
read my book that I just signed a
special copy for Bree I think Briana
actually might be more of an eye he's
licking my feet like you didn't nothing
right now
I'm gonna do this stop it a lot of you
guys are asking it if I did an honorable
version yes there is an honorable person
that you can actually get at audible.com
slash
iJustine you can get a 30 day free trial
bottle and you get a pup for sock pig
just to sell yourself try to tell them
about audible how about would it hey sit
sit right now get every witness that
mean good boy good boy
hey check it out he says I've
accomplished wonders teachers I'm gonna
read it I'm just gonna listen
okay stop licking my feet next question
please okay what is her favorite object
to chew on wait if you.we
what do I like to are we asking Brienne
are we asking about put on what you like
to chew Auklet realize that you on
chocolate but lights that you want
everything everything everything it's
unbelievable when Phil's birthday August
16th August 16th you want one year a lot
of beauty okay about look at you do much
Malo
Oh to me no eat dinner we get here off
your writing my new sweater you're
biting my new sweat Oh
anyways if you guys remember what I did
the Prezi Oakham pain Elmo wonder you
guys got some vlog shoutouts so here I'm
about to you all of your vlog shoutouts
so our first one is Arnaud Arnaud aren't
Arnold Arnold I am unable to read my own
typing I am totally this isn't even like
I gotta have an excuse my like no I
couldn't read my handwriting oh if I
can't read my text oh my god I get a
make my text bigger Oh Arnold thank you
so much you're amazing and I really
apologize that I was unable to say your
name I'm gonna work on that for the next
time Brandon Meyer Mayer brain tumor
thank you so much you're amazing
I love you um free loves you also I do
yeah Duane Homewood that I smell dead
Duane did I say Duane right I think I
did thank you thank you so much I love
you well this one's top Jennifer Malvina
boutique you're freaking awesome
pee daddy yo p JD we'll saw Parker
you're amazing and think it's Ryan thank
you guys so much for supporting this
amazing campaign it was for such a good
cause and you guys made it all happen
and I can't wait to take you and you can
actually see what you guys don't need it
- all right bye bye from hopefully the
next time you see Bri she'll have read
my book but if you didn't uh I've always
listened to me read it to you